we run this what hi
it's Wednesday welcome James my live
perchick here Richie is joining me and
yes you guys if you read the title and
the description we are playing the deer
simulator today the deer simulator so
yeah this game is already looking pretty
wild I don't know if the camera is in
the best position on the screen right
now if it's not we'll fix it however I
don't did this game come out today or
did it come out very recently very
recently maybe even yesterday but well
it's available now that is what we do
now
we are currently playing on Steam and
honestly let's just get to it
enough talk enough talk I feel like this
game will explain itself oh yeah yeah I
think this is an early access build I
think we should also clarify according
to steam so here we go yes the few clips
I've seen so far of this game is pretty
funny Sam and I had like two minutes of
hands-on experience I was like I have to
stop the world needs to see this he
already looks buff let me say that right
now oh those aren't polygons those are
just ABS and like muscles and square
square that's not even the attack look
now it's telling me to attack sounds we
have several questions stretch neck
everything makes sense in this game
don't worry
Wow
you know bro we're like spider-man
almost the whole excuse me horse weight
ride the horse yeah let's go this feels
wrong it's so quiet this is like
borderline cannibalism animal abuse yes
get off all right a lot going on here oh
hello human hey human say hi hi because
that's how we say hi yes
little dance-off that's an option oh my
god what have we created we've created a
monster
created a squad a small squad I need
more human what is going on here let me
see if I can a spider next I can grapple
Oh ten points no that's health where's
my friend he's too died he killed me
Oh
Wow would you like to go
no I am your night enjoying watching you
run amok okay let's let's Dieruff I'm or
humans that was the best wait hold on
whoa I'm in now and control of the car
oh I was consumed any day this is a trip
[Music]
stopped working as soon cuz I wanted a
car because I saw a ramp over here
that's like it was like a Tony Hawk like
loop-de-loop over there we only have a
an e level dere's a stair going on oh I
had to create I have to cause chaos
I need what's up alright we're gonna
turn all the humans into the air
step one let them do our bidding yeah
run with me Frank you guys gotta find
that plane you're right the deer must
fly the old the please yes
here we go right I'm gonna try as soon
as I hear I see it good what is the card
oh oh what a cutscene the police have
been called with the popos oh no they're
gonna send out like some buzz
[Music]
here we go
we're up I'm running out of words this
board we defeated the police word for it
almost wow they're still here what a
massacre Oh Oh that range it's okay my
friends are here yeah we have our trusty
human deer our seed we need to grow the
army I need I want to I want to use the
looky-loo all right why does the police
station have a force field around let's
go check it out come on squad no it's
blocked whoa
one of the dudes made it get out of here
I know he's behind enemy lines wait
there's a clock a clock Oh what there's
a straight-up handgun over here I'm
armed there they are oh my god I saw
that on the trailer and I was like I
need to play this game today how much
ammo
look at the D is going as is increasing
here trying to get like a sea level
disaster oh wait hold up we gotta get
our revenge on this koala yeah I'm dying
all right we were clearly not prepared
now full fury of that koala not at all I
need a bigger squawking over there yeah
always got laser beams this game is a
trip ok we have flying elephants what Oh
No
he's okay
[Music]
okay now I'm gonna try that no you know
what eff the loop-d-loop for now let's
build our gang up this is like in San
Andreas when you build local crew oh
[ __ ] we need that guy okay so we need to
cause some trouble
get the police after us and then get a
gun yep just a symbol I wish you could
GT a style like rip people out of the
car and then purify them yeah you can
only Jack their car there's like no one
in the car when you do that watch out
now excuse me look at the disaster
you know what time all this fuzz holy
crap how are you doing chat I haven't
even set up yet crazy okay here we go
where the axe come on
oh yeah okay here we go
I love that
I've defeated the cops wonderful now
it's all quiet I see two more people to
add to our squad here we go would you
like Oh
under fide one guy otherwise why did he
go so boy so this game is amazing WTF I
know
it's eleven dollars and 69 cents on I'm
just looking at my antlers in amazement
still we're gonna have a big-ass gang
here the whole town's part of my game
exactly we need ya at that koala use me
serve a parade he said how can i play as
a play this says great army it's on
were queer accidentally causing so much
oh shoot a Cotter yeah I accidentally
threw a horse earlier
please wake up there you go is this part
of the goose simulator gaming universe
honestly the animal simulator universe
is expanding yeah whoa no I don't think
they're in direct relation to each other
I see a shark a shark he's chilling wait
wait wait don't antagonize him yet let's
recruit these other folks first okay
like he's good he's on some final boss
status ain't they I pressed dance it's
funny or in a group it pretty slow what
though you sir wait Hey I threw somebody
this is a mess way up
then my crowd my crew runs into them
like okay this crew is alarm let's uh
should we do the plane fight the koala
normal day in my neighbors
I'm older it got stuck behind the
building
look at that what a sight to see
beautiful we are a little deer cold
except they need gun for antlers to
sport nice hairy down this pole
it's gonna love look we got him we have
enough I was gonna say man power that's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
bull is tanki though we feed the cops oh
this is yeah chat is right that is the -
oh and the deer eddie gordo I'll
probably give it to anyone however if
it's Eddie person this whole squad I
don't know no I should have I carry it
on my cheeks
what how do I
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Big Mike says what in the world is this
exactly oh shoot misty said yo I just
wanted to comment that's a guy wildest I
would like to take that opportunity to
say yeah thanks to John Lube Michael hi
I'm Gabe Jewett and everyone that
contributed gameplay Mike McCarty yeah
we made some put some good content which
to that doom gameplay back to the show
[Music]
we are losing hearts
oh no another oh wait she drop her gun
I think I think the big gun Wow Wow wait
no doesn't it tell you when you've
killed or when you've defeated the
police Wow do we keep weight under
construction yeah maybe I can't get to a
level B here's a sir let's get to the
plane
was it back here
bigboy cows we got koala bears and we
got fish in the sky we got to take care
of you
let's dance what is it
I probably wrong but what's that movie
where they like eyes right it's old
movie where they do this fighting style
that's pretty dope runs like space
channel 5 definitely any word of fetes
well the plane didn't move this time did
we ever take off our do anything maybe
it's another ride in it look it was
destroyed hey I think it's time to get
some revenge on the Koala boy we do have
a sniper now don't get laser beams hey
an arcade chord wait homies destroy the
game oh they did
wait I'm still like the blue boy killed
that guy what happened
streets are high
all right I haven't really used my
grappling fighter neck yeah let's see if
I can spider Nick on the cap or do you
think I'll kill me I think he's gonna
have some laser beams too but let's find
out all right
what's that fire a test on fire what
have I done what did that do something
came up I think there's like mini games
or something but like it see on the
bottom left it shows it for like a
second I can't seem to trigger it wait
yeah the basic rules say the same is for
Reversi oh oh okay the pieces move on
their own
being cows okay mmm it is I was not
expecting this of all the things oh we
did you player
cool okay let's see put the cow down hey
only the strong there you go OCR thank
you that is indeed the name you got a
places player too so you have to like
remember anyway
[Music]
I'm not exactly sure what I'm doing the
rules were minimalist but like I need
more hands-on experience
am I supposed to I have okay
well I'm getting more we try the lake
put your piece next to other pieces so
they get more of your pieces yeah there
are more of these black cows that I have
okay we know you got more okay oh yeah
five and five this took a very somber
turn now you have seven how I did that
no we only spawned in 100 I took some of
your cows my cows your cows
what's I forgot what it goes up to if
there's even a number to shapers
[Music]
eventually there will be no more squares
to pick in theory remember where my cows
were crap 20 wow this really flipped on
its head oh my goodness I think do you
think like in order to win like zero me
out that was a nice break from the chaos
yeah the wildness okay I'm back we had
my guns everything's
[Music]
apparently that train was free
joint jump there you go there's that
space jump whoa all right I need gang
members guns and police activity I need
to build my gang back you there oh all
the humans where they had oh there's one
okay they just kind of respawn and you I
called a hunk after they okay we're
starting some [ __ ] here
now it's level one sheep we got to go
back for that koala eventually yeah we
were we were just about ready to also
dang it this is what happens when you
get a gun in this game
oh there they are yeah get up
wonderful Irene the cat is like what the
f am i watching yeah
fair question I would hope that when our
dear overlords come that they make me a
part of their army and they don't just
stand it's the tuna people we have a
pretty big gang let's celebrate
hey we're going ham yes okay I need
better guns and we need to create more
chaos enough dancing sorry just trying
to run there we go
okay
under fight the polar bear police
I hate that guy he is we can't even
start [ __ ] without him killing us do you
want to try are you at all interested
yes the polar constants
oh the how to play menu we'll give you a
refresher on the buttons if you want the
neck grapple thing is hello fine people
you don't have a choice I like to cut up
your genes you're recruited that can
happen that's now there you go
I saw how they do the ninja maroudo run
as soon as they're recruited they're
elevated
a higher state of mind
[Laughter]
[Music]
they're so destructive on accident
although I may be wondering why this
game exists I'm not mad at it oh yeah
not at all
I'm very actually happy with the plane
okay all right how many people we got a
slot or oh yeah
I see you yeah hanging out by the water
done where squad go they're all down
there trying to come back you there the
fuzz I wish it was some music
yeah TV check cool jump
sounds like a sane
[Music]
yeah what yeah we'll tell you if that
was it
there's one ah there they are
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a guy um I don't run him over
all right nice no Jude koalas bad news
in this game why can't we just verify
the Koala guys I'm trying to be nice
there accidentally causing destruction
[Music]
weren't you strong okay no she's running
oh there you go you're stuck
don't forget the gun we're cool yo I
wonder if that lion is like level F he's
probably like yeah like the boss no the
cool wall I don't know it's draft I
calmly approach yeah I can't sprint out
anywhere else the whole squad is
trampled under they did something anyway
oh nice this is tikka gameplay so good
why thank you
I'm just trying to get the ultimate
Hey
[Music]
one big circle squad bowls right here
[Music]
now we're at a level of gear that you
get - thanks dear the gang steer all
right
damn we need to get to that next level
police yeah Judy Hopps levels to get
that cool laser all these dead
[Music]
you know we need more people Bob Joan
are they destroying the world kind of at
least this city today the city from all
the world right they are yeah though
they run into everything they kind of do
it accidentally but it gets us in
trouble you there yeah you there you
there thank you oh there we go
earrings you there the glasses no no
wait guys stop oh the tree just win the
treatment have it there's a car in the
middle of the ocean I just do I feel
like it's our fault
wait yeah I was like there was someone
inside this let me handle this alright
taking off dude bye thanks for tuning in
thanks pre logo but I like it Oh an iron
gamer yes though that is a polar bear
that's the second Ozzy nice buttery
chill
your squad is too huge
I think leave can I write yeah I think
you can just watch it he behaves like a
horse where you can just ride no I think
it's just to recap
you're a dick no time to recap yeah
bring it Judy what about the flying fish
in the sky we haven't really tested that
because we're scared my royalty as I
write a zebra oh my god alright the
whale - we have
[Music]
so much destruction bare stuff your help
no Frasier
you look at your health up top I know
Lou you got the laser gun though six
weapons I have I don't think it replaces
it I think you guys ran over it he was
back there
[Music]
I need help help maybe we shoot a
building there there within the movie
that's how I found a gun earlier I don't
know oh there's the Big Tuna the flying
elephant a small airplane that guys
running for it he said F this dear life
shoot he's gonna die just have to accept
the deer way dad over there across the
farm
as long as it's not hurtful because
we're hello I know it's like a brown
right now well something else goes there
look these are big buttons but cow goes
there it looks like oh and you go there
I think we need a cow or the weight of a
cow hmm you guys squad for once they're
not acting up pelipper developer
oh man be careful I see the Koala I was
so happy I was like wow that's cool and
then it killed me the very first time I
saw it I think is not cool shooting with
your guns ride it you can swim across
all of you follow me I don't like that
thing in the air a lot less eventful
than I thought it was thank ya I saw him
like where we started the level yeah we
do need a cow
I can't believe we're trying to make
sense out of this game because it's
freaking chaotic don't play any
minigames took away every there's the
cow remember you shoot him and he turns
like frozen are you freezes up you don't
have to play the game to collect them no
you there it was probably one of your
teeth
[Music]
can you grab him like the way you grab
your friends cuz he's just floating now
no I don't know what here we go that's
you there
this guy's like I haven't very lost how
do we recruit these guys he rides the
little cows guys are like these guys
stole our core
[Music]
[Laughter]
this cow is freaking out oh one of the
cows are down no like the beginning of
spacejam give up however can i grab
these cows yes you can look but you
can't right yes
[Music]
all right we out let's go
it was over there this is more easy this
is very convenient if that koala zaps us
down the stream he's right there he's
facing the other way you're cool this is
what oh you're too high look at that the
developer there's a street sign I have
zero answers
how are you descending watch out for
thee his help is so much
[Music]
and our one friend I am the deer was it
you say if nothing happens I'm going to
be very sad Oh reinforce a tiger or I
know this game is pulling no punches
[Laughter]
y'all better not destroy my mech no no I
don't know I think you're chilling good
calmly galloping over
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how you do it with full health
this is how we take I should have hid
behind the building my fault we did all
of that okay we've made progress I don't
think I need I think I'm gonna find a
smaller crew to take out the police and
then maybe under them so that we can do
those missions I don't know like the cow
on the scale cuz they get in the way
when there's too many
Killick follows only if you thought
right but this koala he's bad news
yeah oh yeah this one is big and healthy
and not extinct here that gear we can
kill the koala yeah maybe I'm just
causing destruction to get some police
activity out here I also forgot I had
like a speck of life left right yeah I
was so excited by the mechs
oh it's not a human
I'm just checking what qualifies as like
health being drunk I got hit by
something that car in the back also
let's see where we can find help Gannon
says what's that he got guns our side
yep
Oh time for the Pope the polar bear holy
Sh sweet bring it on
[Music]
maybe a little too early for this game
okay what's this oh I wanted help I want
to see if we're we what is this game
oh sorry can be hard to hear we're
making progress with this leave it leave
it
yeah
[Music]
dang it forretress dang it
right no change steam the laser Daniel
Browns has got a heal your super right
except we don't know where to find the
heart you know where you know where they
are
we details
it doesn't look like I can go I can get
in any more trouble see the top right
that looks like a grenade Oh No on my
way car Oh
my own grenade ok good thank God get up
hand gun where are the hearts this is
the number one question I'm not using my
Nick enough wait a nuclear plant
spewing your needs
thank God
that over there I was a car initially
the am i watching yeah well welcome to
the ger simulator I only say that
because that's how it's spelled it is
extra ease for emphasis all right let's
go fly the cow over yeah that was the
cow was like why are all the people in
ours are running right to you so we are
defying all of the humans and surely
when they're terrified we they're under
our control they just follow us around
it's pretty great there are several
questions we have for this we also have
a spider neck we could basically you
know web swing around and dance oh yeah
you there alright person how did you do
this I just walked up to the cow in a
press ball
you have full control oh there's a koala
note for those of you tuning in the
Koala is bad news dangerous he's killed
us like four times we're just trying to
live taming the chap wow I've seen it
all now I've seen it all wait the
meccans there permanently
[Music]
so basically earlier if you didn't see
you guys we flew this cow over and we
stood on this button and the other we
stood on the other button and this mech
was flown in from the graces like even
though it was yelling we so we want the
mech angry angry grizzly said just
finished watching Zootopia the big
coincidence that you're playing a game
with Judy Hopps yeah right judy judy
they should go to area 51
area 51 would be perfect in this game
heck yeah
alright so let's get up in this mech oh
let go of it it's a charge jump alright
I think we can take them out if we hide
behind buildings and stuff the Zebras on
top of the roof now yeah whoa okay I'm
trying to come down here we go I got
wait yeah I bet you koala can't get us
from here seriously
I shot the construction guy
all right silly all right I'm going
straight to the MEC we have a full
half-hour let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
yeah Oh purrs you can just start with
the neck right there that was TV guy
groaning there drum roll please full
he'll go about it the way you want did
he show you know I wasn't I was exactly
so this mech is built with some robot
parts legs legs made with Tigers and
cows and you're shooting BB oh it worked
though
thank goodness the laser stop yeah Nina
speak over Oh God I don't want to
destroy that right now how about the
building he's on good good attempt on
this cuz now we just have access to the
back at all times
if all the rigmarole and guns but can
you shoot the building he's on and does
it take damage hide advances right a
crazy violin dear look at that bear bro
come on we're not the enemy here
yeah maybe go around see if they can
take damage you're looking at me yeah
[Music]
he's cool though alright this mech I
know you would think you would have more
invincibility I got two rhinos on my
thighs all right Trey in the chat says
what the actual really fun at first I
was expecting to be totally like jokey
which it is but there's actually some
cool stuff like that a little puzzle
good to fly the tower
I like recruiting people
come on you run out of booth now oh here
oh oh well at least we have come back to
take on the sheet
already level 2 level 1 hasn't arrived
damn this is a way to go about it
whoo chata suggesting the CSIs typische
we haven't done it yeah
[Music]
here oh damn it there you go you have to
shoot back there there it is yeah
it's so quiet when you're not like
causing total destruction the helipad
[Music]
can you destroy the police it's so far
now of course when we want to shoot it
wait it seems oh there was like a
lighting effect then come back okay well
that was that wait did he drop something
dropped something blue grenade that it
you can't even equip it in the mag well
that's an enemy for those who were
wondering
yeah he's killed assume anytime I wonder
if I just go chill on top of his
building yeah that's so funny you can
shoot the construction guy there you go
that's what helped me get down to you
from up here nice now I have the height
advantage all right the aiming is kind
of
but he's got hitting you yeah then he
moves like his head a little bit he's
steamin why didn't I
that was that was false I had the height
advantage building was intact
koalas ope he's Opie I want to know what
happens if we do take him out
oh my goodness
that's it I don't know I think it's
impossible to kill this fool
we took damage off of him though you got
it you had a like perfect neck suit
dodging you would think
oranjee he said it's over koala of the
high ground site you know we tried to be
the swallows friend every we did I
looked up at it I think I the very first
time I like what they call it crap hold
on to him then yeah I killed me we run
this town koala
[Music]
it's kind of hard to control yeah it
wasn't very fluid boy oh dang from up
here let's go yeah ray if I'm like if I
got construction man holding let go he's
like I'm how we know the police building
can be destroyed what if we behind hide
behind there all right you know what
there's gonna be a bet oh okay I got an
idea I don't know but we'll see oh my
gosh this thing is so I see where you're
going though my hide behind the bubble
oh I don't know president that's like if
I crouch down all right you know I'm
sick of you oh yeah we're gonna do this
all calculated you guys hungry pro
strats Pro dear sim strats
oh my gosh okay okay okay I think this
is a good spot oh you got you too
yes look at watch this help go down come
on watch it go down
ding I like missed the angle Oh ripp I
hit it one time I couldn't find the
angle again alright that's the spot
though I'm determined now the police
building or the police station they're
not lost that one's fun I also feel like
just after a certain amount of time of
him laser beaming you just died
regardless of as he's reading right now
oh man that's how it look just not the
case okay got this
whoops this one feels dangerous yeah
you're right in the sights he's looking
he knows
I think if you did you do it a
continuous three maybe the zeros like I
don't know
I don't want to move if I move all right
that's not the wave it's not the way I
tried it twice it's all the convincing I
need the mechs doesn't move very well so
even if I try the dodging we've it's not
gonna be fast enough to dodge the laser
Oh My lordy Lordy lordy all right
I'm writing it up he's hurting me you
killed me like five guys already I mean
oh you got half this out that was good I
was like maybe the falling animation
will be enough to legs but once I hit
the ground I couldn't really move did
you make it to the ground I thought I
killed you
and I'd like touch the ground I tried to
move it it's kind of clunky weird a nose
for cows oh you have seen nothing yet we
flew a cow now this is the ultimate mech
right here look how beautiful the thing
is we got two rhinos mm-hmm there are
the thigh nose right there no Tigers all
right there's the deer what about this
I'll see you like I can't
[Music]
[Music]
all right take over it okay here we go
giant koala has defeated me one too many
times you see if I can try like a ground
approach you know we in our worm within
beaten up the building huh oh crap
yeah you have a blind spot right Michael
yeah he agrees saying go directly below
the koalas yeah
where they keep spamming even go to
timeout broski okay
what game will we be streaming tomorrow
Kingdom Hearts 3 mine DLC it will be out
mañana yeah I just want to try it with
the big gun with the big guns I can be
on foot trade the shoot from the top
stuff please address grenades yeah it's
like a beanie
[Music]
oh yeah Bernie
[Music]
whoa oh yeah top of the building and for
me and yeah all right well you know what
if I'm in the back I can't do that we
still never found help causing more
damage you hit Oh
Grey's apamea
yeah I feel like you know you can be
stopped
yeah calm down hey maybe that's how we
chip away at him you guys back off I
don't need this right now
oh no not the tiny the buildings
the sun's going down we lived for a
whole day sir all right let's see here
just looking for a good spot
yeah the auto lock with the light guns
kind of makes it hard to hide behind a
building sometimes to shoot like see how
it's Auto locking on see like the
environment
[Laughter]
Oh your dear friends okay oh my that's
good to know you can chip away at him
I'm try one more time maybe just what
the Mac I'll tip away all the guns you
can at least run like this and a dodge
delays it that's true is it easy to is
it easy to walk with the Mac it's like
this regular one I mean we could try
shooting him like from the butt oh yeah
but he does turn around eventually yeah
ranae's
name them real quick all right thank you
it works see how he turns around like I
feel like if we were underneath them
he'd still be able to shoot us
probably yeah turn his head but one way
to find out let me see if I can hide
behind the building all right setting up
here
let him cool off can't do damage to his
own building off of another building or
something I don't know this koala is
advancing Oh he picking away at him okay
good that looks like Oh
at least a laser is it
[Music]
I need a better gun yeah okay
we're close to getting Judy there we go
sideburn newzeas yep yeah see I want to
save that big red dog
damn that another grenade yeah dang it
let's see what these can do when we get
ready good another this is a safe spot
oh I never heard that music before I
know
yeah not sure what happened there
all right let's get through the
advantage points okay all right so this
is the spot right here
good thing the cow is ablaze arena yeah
that does nothing
destroy everything all right stop
are you ready hey that's a lace go that
delay is pretty cool I keep looks at you
but you have a few seconds we can do
this oh my god
oh oh it's immediately nighttime all of
a sudden come on fine but these are the
the rabbits now little tougher I pull
help though things are going good
yeah if you died Judy's right now oh my
god don't let it happen
that move still works really well in
some movies okay where the rabbits come
on
I feel like down the other side of that
wall and they think they're like you
speakin
boo-bear
okay oh there they go
fully equipped except for the AKS
actually okay
koalas honoring her giant koalas going
down that was our proudest
accomplishment what happened
maybe Lou is he gonna dissolve drop it
something dropped in a cave
hmm man that was anti-climatic don't
[Laughter]
[Music]
like suffering it kind of sucks worth
the okay there's that guy we didn't try
to shoot the flying elephant climb on
top of them playing with this corpse
yeah don't let him kill me
[Music]
all right what we got them I know I'm
like I don't know I feel about this now
all right that's what happens when you
what's left the flying elephant there's
the airplane yeah whenever we can like
try to use mine how high can I go with
this yeah we had zebra oh shoot there
you go this one's big yeah what the heck
I hate him epic
I am truly a king oh wow okay yeah let's
explore this town my one dear friend
it's a new day still nothing
[Music]
we killed that thing already right drop
like a grenade find the flying swinging
not at all it's smoother than I thought
to maybe not soon I'll have nothing to
swing hmm all right what do you want to
see like if we can I think you can fly
him how okay gets pretty close to the
baby the MEC oh yeah it never gets old a
little whiff sound yeah sit over here or
am i tripping okay unequip I would never
want to do that
there's a plane oh wait I wonder if you
have to take the baby dear it see the
mother dear maybe they're lost they're
separated cuz there's a little deer oh
the zebra yeah oh yeah I said be right
what's the baby deer a do you bro
alright good thing you're playing three
minutes left yeah let's take the baby to
the mama I bet you that's a thing
they must be reunited let's see if it
does anything look at the graphics on
the deer I know the zebra so trippy
hahaha oh I forgot about these minigames
- I wonder if doing them accomplishes
anything but you know what it did it the
first time in fact it took everything
away zebra mama zebra sorry this is this
koala won't go away
yeah yeah there you go
or were they getting beat up dang it I
thought they were like dancing like
yelling galloping
all right elephant time yes that will be
the last thing we do whoops yeah yeah
like the shotgun sound it makes it does
all dang alright would you want me to
see like shoot it down or like see if we
can whenever I already asked that
[Music]
oh yeah that's I was looking for that
gosh straight ahead there we go
next time
okay now he's coming for you no is your
own grenades they keep running into me
alright how did you
what do you do took all right shoot him
watch that like geez
this is a mess it isn't so smoothly
control yeah I was like the mech doesn't
fly as intuitively as you might think
wait but it is early access oh well ah
like a new day I don't know what shop
[Music]
[Music]
now I feel terrible
couldn't say I mean that's what I
connected I guess but inspect I'm a
monster yeah thank you so much for
tuning in
it was a grand old time what a trip $11
interesting I think early access if we
didn't mention earlier so more things to
come from this game I'm assuming but
yeah tons of fun had a great time nice
to just sit back and have a laugh yeah
hope you guys enjoyed it too don't
forget every weekday right here on the
GameSpot YouTube channel on 11:00 a.m.
Pacific time we're gaming and we're here
and we're doing all kinds of things so
hopefully you'll come back next time
hope you enjoyed what you saw and until
the next stream we'll see you guys later
bye
you